hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the US Championship
2022 this one is from round seven round
eight has already been played but this
is a nice game that I've missed it was
recommended to me by my brother-in-law
zaro who also runs a chess Channel if
you haven't seen it do check it out uh
he also made an analysis of this game
and he enjoys studying Theory a bit more
than me so if you guys want to learn
about the the moves that were played
here a bit more in depth I will put a
link to his review of the game will be
the first link in the description below
so it's a wonderful game Ray Robson
versus Wesley so in it features an
incredible line of the names of Indian
defense uh so let's dive straight into
it uh Ray with the white pieces opens
with D4 we have Knight to F6 by Wesley C
for E6 Knights the C3 end as advertised
Bishop to B for the names of Indian
defense E3 going for the standard stuff
here castles and now Knight to F3 and
here the standard moves are D5 C5 and B6
those are the moves that you will I
usually see team but here Wesley plays
Bishop captures on C3 it's very rare as
it doesn't accomplish much so it comes
more as a surprise to rain and then it
actually should be played at this level
but you have to try something because
Wesley is higher rated and he has to
play for the win with the black pieces
so here we have B captures and C3 and
now Pawn to D6 with Bishop to D3 uh Pawn
to E5 and now Pawn to E4 and pawn to E4
uh is the new move and it's a very very
interesting one because it allows black
to Simply win a pawn here we have Rook
the E8 and now you're threatening just
Rook captures Here pawn captures and
Knight captures on e4 but that's exactly
what Ray wanted here Ray castles and uh
he's offering a full Pawn so can Wesley
capture this Pawn uh the pawn can be
captured but you have to play incredibly
precisely after you you actually capture
it so e captures on D4 C counters Knight
captures an E4 Bishop not captures but
rather Rook to E1 not just threatening
to win the Knight Knight to F6 and now
Rook captures an E8 Queen characters and
now yes you do have the bishop pair
you've sacrificed one pawn and now you
have to make the bishop pair come alive
uh you will do this by putting the bash
pun B2 claiming this long diagonal the
lights reversial controls this diagonal
and you will play D5 to open up the dark
Square Bishop's diagonal But First Pawn
to H3 it stops any that Bishop G4 ideas
and also you will want to start
advancing this Pawn to G4 and the G5
then the Bishops will nicely uh well
just slice the entire board in half and
you even have some ideas of maybe
bringing the Rook to G1 to attack the
black king so it's a very very
aggressive line we have Knight beat the
D7 and now Queen to C2 and now if the
Knight moves of course the H7 Pawn
becomes weak B6 Wesley prepares the
Finca to the light Square bishop and now
Bishop to B2 Wesley goes for Bishop to
B7 but now just Pawn to D5 and look at
the bishop pair now this is now a fully
operational Bishop pair and Wesley will
have to figure out what to do with the
light Square Bishop so he is up upon but
his light Square Bishop uh pretty much
out of commission for the moment and now
you know that this Rook for the moment
is coming to E1 and then the queen
really does not have any good Square so
Queen to f8 now ready to meet Rook to E1
with Rook to E8 but here Ray just plays
G4
and now playing Rook to E8 doesn't
really make all that much sense if you
play Rook to E8 now just G5 kicks away
the Knight and then you pick up the H7
Pawn so you have to address the threat
of G5
um after this uh Pawn to G4 move so here
we have Ponte H6 and now King the H2 as
the G file uh might open up then Rook to
G1 could be very very strong so here a
Wesley has to figure out how to continue
this game and it's definitely not easy
one thing you could consider is to
undermine the center with a move like B5
then the the D5 Pawn becomes weak
another thing that you could do is play
Rook the E8 but again it's a very hard
to calculate all the ins and outs
because after g5h captures and Rook to
G1 you have to play G4 give back the
pawn to close the G file and after H
captors you will play Knight to E5
something like this and after Knight
captures here D captures now comes G5
and now for example Knight H5 and this
is the position you would get white
still has the incredibly strong Bishop
pair the well the white king is a bit
loose but um you know it's it's it's
it's a completely crazy position Wesley
still has to figure out how to develop
the bishop probably you can shift it
into the game somehow but for the moment
it's
um it's not all that uh likely how but
okay in the game Wesley played Pont the
C6 instead this is how he wants the bust
open the center uh but this gives Ray
just enough time to start an incredible
attack and he does so with Pawn to G5 H
cat person G5 Knight captures on G5 and
now again it's very hard to find a move
here for Wesley Queen to E7 probably the
most precise one but here he plays C
characters on D5 and now the position is
winning for raid but you have to find
the only line that that is winning it's
such a such a cool line now I'm sure you
guys will enjoy it if you find it so
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for Rey while I'll give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
incredible maneuver and for those of you
who just won't enjoy the show it is best
shop to H7 check so nothing uh you know
spectacular about a nice Bishop check
but it's what comes after that count so
of course the bishop cannot be captured
if you capture the bishop then it's just
mate Queen captures on H7 and after King
the h8 what was played in the game now
comes the move you had to see after
Bishop to H7 and that is Bishop to F5
with the simple threat of just Bishop
characters on D7 and then if Knight
captures again Queen to H7 is Checkmate
so Wesley needs to deal with this he
plays Knights the E5 which is the
absolute best move in the now Ponta F4
kicking away this Knight and again
opening up this diagonal Knights the G6
other moves aren't really all that much
better but this allows a a very nice
breakthrough with Bishop captures and F6
G captures and F6 and now just Knight
captures on F7 eliminating the knights
Defender Queen captures and the bishop
cap ultrasound G6 and the black is still
up material but his King is completely
wide open and it is very very easy to
attack that black king So Wesley has to
set up some sort of a defense so Queen
to E7 now uh White uh goes Queen to F2
preparing Queen Tage for check so F5 now
the queen guards the H4 square and now
Rook to G1 we have rooked the G8 uh and
it now comes Rook to G5 you could also
play some like Queen F3 to try and get
the queen to H5 Abba Ray just goes to
Rook to G5 and now the queen gets access
to the H4 Square Rook to G7 by Wesley we
have Queen to H for check King to G8 and
now the beautiful queen to H5 and now
again uh the the the problem is if you
play something let's say Ponte A6 uh
Bishop H7 check just crushes black king
to a f8 rook captures on F5 with the
check Rook to F7 and now even Bishop to
G6 there's no move you can play here
Queen to h8 is coming and the dash State
there's no good move here or you have to
give up a full Rook so that's pretty
much it yeah so Wesley plays Bishop the
C8 it's it's a nicer idea because the
the F5 Pawn is now defended and it's uh
not all that clear how to win this there
is only one move that allows the array
to win the game so feel free to pause
the video for the second time and try to
find this idea uh while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh you know
probably finding the least interesting
move but that's the move that wins the
game and for so uh who just want to
enjoy the show it is C captress on D5
now it's such a silly move to play
because there's all this action
happening here and everything is tied up
uh the problem is if you don't capture
this how are you winning this let's say
you continue now I'm gonna show you what
happens if you just continue with Wesley
played without actually capturing this
pawn and that is let's say you go Queen
to H6 and it's fine uh what can you do D
captures and C for now happens and now
you once you play Bishop to H7 check
King to f8 and Rook to G2 yes The Rook
is still tied tied down you can't move
the Rook anywhere but now Bishop to B7
and what do you play now uh you don't
have rookie two the queen covers that
the The Rook is attacked so best the
best you can do is just captures
captures and our Queen captures on D6
but you will not be winning this game
King F7 and black is very happy here uh
so what you have to do after this bishop
to see it is just play C counters on D5
this closes up this diagonal and well
does not give black the the free C pawn
and not black is without a move uh
Wesley tried Ponte A5 he has the two to
one advantage on the queen side so he
might be able to create a pass Pawn if
Ray doesn't really do all that much but
now Queen H6 we have Pawn to B5 and now
Bishop to H7 check King to f8 and now
Rook to G2 but now it was in this
position on move 35 that Wesley so
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here now the problem is
without this bishop to B7 move there's
uh really no counter play whatever you
do it just loses the game for example
you start pushing on the queen side just
Bishop captures on F5 and now the h8
square becomes available to the White
Queen let's say Bishop captures on F5 uh
Queen h8 check King to F7 Now The Rook
Hanks King to F6 and a nice open
discover 3 King to F7 and queen to G7
will be Checkmate one of the
possibilities and on the other hand if
you don't want to allow this if you
really want to keep this Pawn you could
play something like Queen to F7 but now
you've moved the queen from the e fast
so just rookie two and now look at this
bishop covers G8 so the king can't go
their King can't go to E7 to E8 uh how
do you stop Queen captures on D6 that's
just a disgusting position to face Queen
D7 now a simple Queen to F6 check Rook
to F7 and the nice Queen to h8 Checkmate
as The Rook still covers the file so
incredible stuff by by Ray incredible
Pawn sacrifice that allowed this it
wasn't uh that the pawn sacrifice was
winning or anything it was just uh I
mean it was just a very very interesting
just utilizing the bishop pair like this
and it all came down to this moment
basically where Wesley played Ponta C6
here if you if you find this uh it's not
uh Pleasant to play it gives black a
really bad position but also also if you
find B5 then maybe you can continue the
game but other than that once C6 was
played yeah it was all downhill for for
black so incredible uh game by by Ray
Robson against the names of Indian
defense truly a magnificent line and uh
with uh and he broke 2700 for the first
time he also won a game after this in
round eight uh so he even passed 2700 I
think he's like 27 or something he's
number 37 and now in the world I will
check I don't want to trick you guys uh
yeah he's currently no he's currently
number 20 35 with 2706 and he's
currently up 16 rating points so very
very nicely done by him and uh yeah he's
doing he's doing really really well in
this tournament if you guys are
interested in the standings I will even
give you that uh the standings are as
follows uh first place for the moment
Fabiano corwana with 6 out of eight
followed by five and a half out of eight
Ray Robson then with four and a half we
have a whole lot of people uh Jeffrey
xiong Darius Samuel sevillan uh and a
Wonder link and uh um Dominguez Perez
with four points we have Sam shankland
with three and a half Alexander lender
and Christopher you and Wesley so with
three Han smoking Neiman and Levon
arunyan and elsan moradabadi with one
and a half points in last place
currently uh so yeah that's the game and
the standings hope you guys enjoyed it
like I said if you want to learn a bit
more about these lines in depth to do
check out yazado's video it will be the
first link in the description below as
he does a more thorough job uh covering
the lines he's a great student of the of
the theory himself so uh for those of
you who enjoyed that then do check it
out uh so yeah that's the game I hope
you guys enjoyed it and a little bit of
standings I would like to thank Lynn
Herbert congratulations Dr Taco Francis
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day